now with Moore is the host of Tommy
Lauren is fearless on outkick Tommy
lahren and former senior advisor to
president Trump Stephen Miller all right
so Tommy we begin with operation keep
Joe Biden from falling on his face uh
didn't actually have a great first day
because he nearly fell on his face again
going down the shorter stairs of Air
Force One you really can't make that up
can you
no and it's pretty sad that we're at
this point now that we're worried that
the leader of the Free World can get on
and off stairs even the smaller stairs
without incident or accident but you
have to wonder what the rest of the
world is thinking you know our enemies
are waiting to pounce and they see this
man who can't even take the kitty stairs
and if there's ever a time to pounce now
would be the time and there's no
coincidence that you've got tens of
thousands of people coming across our
border each and every single week they
see this man that can't mountain and get
up the stairs on his own and they know
that this is the time for them to take
over America to come for everything that
we have our enemies see it Putin sees it
of course the ayatollahs see it the
world sees it and how embarrassing that
this has to be their primary focus let's
just make sure that our president
doesn't fall down today also because the
vice president could be potentially even
worse that's where the Democrat Party is
and Gavin Newsom he's loving this more
than anybody else I have a feeling
uh I think so but he swears up and down
left and right that he's not running
under any circumstances all right
Stephen Miller as I as I look at all
this today uh you know he goes to label
the acronym
um oh it doesn't matter what we call it
because he couldn't remember it
um then you have nearly fall on the
first day of operation don't let Biden
fall again uh then of course you know
you you put that on top of what we
learned last week he bumps into a
flagpole doesn't shake the hand of his
Brazilian counterpart to buy wanders
away
um and you know it's like every single
time he opens his mouth even when it's
not a disaster it's mumbling bumbling
almost incoherent from him it's
obviously his cognitive issues are
getting worse and it's impacting his you
know physical health as well
how do they stick with this guy
well the pace of the decline is
accelerating quickly Sean let's not
mince words this is a horror show the
White House placed a story today about
operation don't let Joe trip where
they're going to put him in comfy
support sneakers and they're going to
have him go up the little staircase the
back entrance to Air Force One and the
man still nearly toppled down a flight
of stairs in the view of the entire
world he cannot put two sentences
coherently together as you say he's
mumbling and bumbling and stumbling not
to mention this whole trip which was
clearly a response to president Trump
going down to speak to the Auto Workers
is completely nonsensical because
they're protesting Joe Biden's policy
Sean it's his climate policies it's his
energy mandates it's his trade policies
his inflation his bad economy that is
driving down wages and living conditions
and employment opportunities for Auto
Workers so we have a president that
can't speak can't talk can't walk can't
move and his economic policies are
leading to ruin Nation for America's
working and middle class you know what
it was reported we don't have it on tape
Tommy but it was reported it was widely
reported about this incident when he was
with you know a group of of you know
doing a fundraiser group of supporters
Financial supporters so I don't know if
you've ever met anybody that has
dementia even early onset or Alzheimer's
look it's sad it's tragic I've seen it
up front up close and personal you don't
wish that on anybody but with that said
is one of the classic symptoms of of
this type of cognitive decline is what
happened at this private meeting where
he told the story
you know and then a few minutes later
not remembering that he just told the
story told it again you know another
characteristic would be you know people
ask you a question you give them an
answer and a few minutes later they'll
ask you the question again and 10
minutes after that they might even ask
at another time very classic symptoms
that are now you know beginning to
become very public so
I mean we can only imagine the shape
he's going to be in you know a year from
now
they can't hide this much longer Sean
and they know that and that's why
there's a panic mode going on right now
with the DNC because they know they have
to get rid of Joe they're not really
worried about that I don't think that
they worry too much about pushing him
off to the side they worry what they're
going to do about their Kamala situation
they can get Joe out of the way but how
do they get over Kamala Harris how do
they install Gavin Newsom over Kamala
Harris because Kamala Harris is quite
frankly their worst nightmare so I think
it's interesting Gavin swears up and
down that he's not running but you have
to listen to the way that he says that
he's not going to run against Joe but
it's not as if he's not going to be the
replacement for Joe so the way that he
discusses this I hang on every single
word that he says so make no mistake the
Democrats they're done with Joe they're
tired of Joe they can't hide this much
longer but they gotta figure out their
Kamala situation and that's where they
have the hang up because they push the
identity politics and they don't know
how to LeapFrog her with the white man
from California with the good hair
that's a hard sell to the party that has
been built around identity politics
that's their challenge best of luck
yeah last word Steve yes they're they're
they're in an impossible situation and
they have no way out they can't get
around the Kamala Harris problem because
they have lived by identity politics
they've made that their highest order so
they can't go around her to get to Gavin
Newsom but they can't get rid of Joe
Biden so ultimately it's going to be a
total train wreck plus they have RFK Jr
who maybe will run as a third party they
don't know what to do but my advice to
Republicans is keep your eye on the ball
keep these investigations going do not
relent do not stop till all the facts
are uncovered
okay and it's Cornell West it's RFK uh
junior maybe talk it's talking to the
libertarian party then you got the No
Labels party that's a lot of potential
third party competition all right thank
you both thank you Tommy thank you Steve
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else